Owen Brown is spending the rest of his
life with me Owen Brown is spending the
rest of his life with me who is Owen
Brown the voice that's being whispered
in the background is this video actually
cursed and who even is Sarah Ali the
creator of this video it's a YouTuber
who has been contacted by the person who
made this Quran recitation thing like
they got mishis and in the background
there was someone speaking M so we was
under the assumption this is some kind
of a I decided I wanted Owen Brown back
so I chose to use the Law of Attraction
and positive affirmations to attract him
at the same time I learned from my
Muslim friends that the Quran is
effective in curing the evil
[Music]
eye and I suspected I might be affected
by devil eye because I was experiencing
back pain as a result I combined the
affirmations I created about Owen Brown
with recitations from the Quran now I
want to tell you an information for my
privacy if you allow me please sure Owen
Brown is dead he died in a car
accident Prophet mhammad peace be upon
him said Sak gets in the way of Calamity
brothers and sisters your sodak is a ban
for you it is a witness for you wouldn't
it be amazing for you to support people
in Turkey Syria Pakistan Afghanistan
Palestine and many other places around
the world with one umah where they are
helping those who have been flicted by
floods by War by earthquakes donate now
brother and sister inah and get your SAR
and Hereafter brother and sisters not
many people are as fortunate as us
please donate whatever you can even if
it's one pound do not look at the amount
you give but rather look at the
intention behind the amount you give
enjoy the
video brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inah so
am I here with I'm here with hello how
you doing alhamdulillah that's good if
you remember about a year ago year and a
half ago I done a video about um the
Quran U recitation by mishari
Surah Bak you don't remember yeah okay
you probably do you're just being fake
yeah no no serious you don't know okay
so I did you know um and you told me not
to watch it so I'm I'm going in this new
did I tell you not to watch it this one
not this one no the one I did no okay
you see in this video as well so this is
a YouTuber who has been contacted by the
person who made this Quran recitation
thing like they got mishis and in the
background there was someone speaking so
we was under assumption this is some
kind of a yeah so be careful told people
to be careful it got 1.2 million views
on my channel and it got really viral in
different places as well yeah so we're
going to watch this and react this
person called Sarah Ali who had the
YouTube channel got in contact with him
and the story unfolds in a very bizarre
way so this is the vaccine to the viral
we're going to see because it looks like
that person was not even a Muslim and
she was in love with someone that she's
mentioning in the back of the Quran okay
but let's watch in so this is what
happened inshallah so for those who are
watching I'm going to speed up the video
on 1.5 so you guys know um because the
video is quite long and we are R for
time what I'm about to show you is one
of the most insane things to happen in
YouTube history and I'm not even
exaggerating it you know how there's
these YouTubers who are doing lost media
type videos where they're talking about
obscure and forgotten content that's
been lost to time and there's these big
searches going on trying to find this
lost piece of media and then years later
some random person who wasn't even
involved in the search accidentally
finds the Lost media somewhere in his
attic or somewhere on a garage sale
today something like this just happened
to me but instead of me finding the lost
media the Lost media found
[Music]
me now let's get back back to the very
very beginning to explain the story a
couple of years ago someone uploaded a
video onto YouTube titled Quran for
Sleep which is basically like a 10hour
long Quran reading of some famous Muslim
priest there's a guy basically reciting
the Quran okay on first glance you
wouldn't really see anything weird with
this video it just seemed like something
people would listen to while they're
sleeping so that you know they're closer
to God when they're sleeping you know
some people just like that it's
basically the Muslim version of
listening to rain sounds while you're
asleep basically you know what I mean
but then something very weird happened
because some people who listen to it
noticed a second voice whispering in the
background and if you listen very
closely to the second voice you can even
hear what it's saying you're from
swallowing pills I can swallow pills
easily I can swallow pills like anybody
Owen Brown is spending the rest of his
life with me Owen Brown is spending rest
of his life with me Owen Brown is coming
back to orc University for me Owen Brown
listened to every word I say to him Owen
Brown listened to every order I give him
Owen Brown listen to every word I say to
him yeah bro this is freaky okay bro
this is the video I don't I don't you
you haven't seen it but we noticed this
and we was like hold on a second what is
that cuz I used to play as well so
what's that in the background bro so I
done this video which went viral warning
people do not listen cuz this can be S
bro you're listening to the Quran but
subconsciously or whatever it is for
that for that matter now this person has
named herself Sarah Ali we're going to
watch now how she got in we don't she is
that matter go in contact no not LGBT
literally go in contact with this guy
yeah so she was in love with this guy
Owen jnes yes and Owen Brown Owen Owen
Brown Owen Brown so you heard that Owen
Brown's going to live the rest of his
life with me damn yeah so let's let's
carry on Imes okay perfect I'm not even
exaggerating spooked out millions of
people the original original Quran for
Sleep video by Sarah Ali got over 7
million views and if you looked through
the comments every single comments is
saying this video is black magic it's
cursed stay away there's like hundreds
of videos some of them with millions of
views warning people to not watch Quran
for sleep because it's cursed bro so
this video is one of the biggest
internet Mysteries Ever just the biggest
what the going on mystery ever and there
were major unanswered questions about
this video like who is Owen Brown the
voice that's being whispered in the
background is this video actually cursed
and who even is Sarah Ali the creator of
this video so after all those years no
one really understood what this video is
about and the Mystery revolving Quran
for Sleep slowly faded
out until now because a couple of days
ago
I got an
email dear rat alive I hope this message
finds you
well I recently came across your video
discussing me and I would like to
clarify things I am interested in
collaborating with you to share my full
story as I believe this could help clear
some of the misconceptions surrounding
me I have seen various YouTubers create
content ENT about me but I chose to
reach out to you because I believe you
are a genuine individual who would
respect my privacy thank you for your
time and I look forward to hearing from
you
soon best
regards Sarah
[Music]
Ali what what the
attached to the email was this so one
thing that's bizarre is that out of
everybody she I don't know who this
YouTuber is by the way I don't know who
he is his name is what is his name is it
Owen Brown no his name is
R yeah I I don't know what his content
is I don't know what it's about but this
is now picking up traction so yeah so
this is she's in contact with him she
emails him and let's see the story why
who is Owen Brown why did she do that is
it black magic or not let's find
out which apparently shows her YouTube
Studio analytics page where you can see
the Quran for Sleep video 10 hours long
7.1 million views just like the original
So I responded hey there wow this is
probably the most unexpected message
I've ever received which is true I think
it would be extremely interesting to
know your perspective on the whole Quran
for Sleep Legend we could definitely hop
on Discord call if you'd like or did you
have anything else in mind all the best
rad out this is probably the the most
horrible email I've ever written in my
entire life 2 hours later response hello
I am reaching out to share my full story
I am open to using Discord however for
privacy reasons I prefer to communicate
by typing on Discord rather than through
voice calls thank you for your
understanding and then she basically
sent me her Discord ad to message her on
Discord you know but the thing is I
wanted to hop on a call bro I I want to
hear Sarah Ali's voice bro I want to see
if it's an actual woman or some random
14-year-old that's pranking me right so
I made her an offer okay I see I just
sent you an invite on Discord if you'd
like we could also hop on a call but I
could change your voice of AI that way
your voice is basically unrecognizable
but whatever you're comfortable with so
I sent her this email and I waited for a
response checking my inbox every few
minutes nothing absolute silence and I
was like no way did I just scare her off
off bro no way I just scared off Sarah
Ali because it got a bit too greedy bro
I literally had her
Manan what happened are you okay what
are you talking about you got scared H
you
jumped no but it's about to get more
Sinister bro this a matting bro the
story who she really is is crazy
she accepted my
invite okay let's see so I click on my
Discord and this is her first message
hello I prefer typing because people can
identify my accent and guess where I'm
from whether it's Germany France Italy
Japan Norway or Brazil or America bro
why she why she typing like that all
right she's a bit secretive okay James
Bond I responded I see are you generally
more of a private person or is it
because of the whole Quran for Sleep
controversy she said I am private person
I don't want people to find my true
identity so shall I start telling you my
story well if you really want to tell me
what happened so there was a guy named
Owen Brown who was a mutual Crush I did
not finish he liked me and I liked him
back he was hinting that he had feelings
for me but I was waiting for a
confession from him at a party I
attended with people I know and Owen
Brown a stranger approached me and
started talking to me being a polite
person I didn't feel comfortable telling
that stranger to leave me alone as a
result Owen Brown dumped me because of
that stranger talking to me for about 12
minutes feel free to ask any question
while I'm telling my
story so far we've got a story line
party now we know non-muslims when it
comes to certain they don't really have
yeah they don't really have it so this
this attitude to me I'll be honest with
you seems out of place it it's out of
place like if it's a Muslim man like
someone speaking to a girl you like you
get it this is where you like so is he a
Muslim is she a Muslim and this happened
in this party whatever it is for that
matter or what is it for do you get it
so the fact that he dumped her just
because someone spoke to cuz usually
nonl I've been I've been a non-muslim
you know they don't care bro some of the
girls go and chat and bro in Jia bro
some of the girls will go and do some
mad dance with other guys and they like
yeah you know I'm I'm I'm not insecure
yeah okay another interesting thing is
brown is spelled with an e that's not
how people in the west spell it yeah
yeah and you're going to notice this
because he mentions she makes spelling
mistakes is it on purpose or not holy
Yap I see what happened then after some
time I decided I wanted Owen Brown back
so I chose to use the Law of Attraction
and positive affirmations to attract him
at the same time I learned from my
Muslim friends that the Quran is a
effective in curing the evil
[Music]
eye and I suspected I might be affected
by devil eye because I was experiencing
back
pain however when I went to the doctor
the doctor told me I was fine as a
result I combined the affirmations I
created about Owen Brown with
recitations from the Quran listening to
both at the same time to save time now
this is a little bit bizarre why would
she find the need Quran she's clearly
not Muslim she's not Muslim and she said
her Muslim friends told her to I think
they told her look maybe you got evil
eye or whatever it is so listen Bak is
known for the gy I really like this guy
and I couldn't get him you have evil eye
you know how Muslims are it's a gin
everything is a gin Everything's Magic
everything they never take
accountability you know what it is it's
like there was a little joke but it's a
bit kuy like you'll be careful by he's
like people yeah why' you do the sin the
Shan made me do it why did you that the
Shayan and then Shayan pops on goes
listen my friend take blame you done it
stop blame like stop blaming me for
everything do you get it yeah do you get
it this one actually swear with he
actually swears it goes you son of a
yeah stop blaming me all the time you
son of a yeah yeah it's not really swear
word to be honest anyways yeah okay
let's carry
on did you understand this
part
holy skito mode bro what the the [__] am
I reading man so at this point I was
thinking to myself bro I'm going in some
rabbit hole that I'm not going to come
out of anytime soon bro evil eye devil
eye what the hell is that what exactly
is the evil eye the evil eye is a curse
in Muslim faith they say when someone is
jealous of you the jealousy can
materialize as back pain or headaches or
Worse okay so because you got back back
pain you thought someone cursed you with
the evil eye yes true some Christians
believe in Devil eyes and I am
Christians
Christians multiple is that a typo you
know and the thing that made me kind of
suspicious about this person she would
always make these very weird grammatical
errors when she's typing to me right as
if she isn't really fluent in English at
all so I was always like suspicious that
this person might not be Sarah Ali but
some random guy from India trying to
prank me right so I decided to really
interrogate her and see just how well
her story is built So I responded but
why did you put the affirmations and the
Quran together why not just listening to
it separately because I found it
challenging to listen to the affirmation
I made about Owen Brown for 20 minutes
and then having to listen to the Quran
for 4 hours so I combined both together
by looping the affirmation about Owen
alongside the
Quran okay so she basically speed ran uh
prayer something like that okay so he
basically wanted to speedrun Healing
yourself from the devil eyes and making
Owen Brown comeback so you did both at
the same time yeah basically right just
a speed run in prayer bro let me just
listen to three things at once bro maybe
I'm going to get healed faster yes I
wanted to do a speedrun LOL and there
was a good reason why why I uploaded
those videos to YouTube although I made
them for myself yeah what was the reason
and then she said something that made my
alarm Bells go off I didn't want to fill
my mobile phone storage with a 4-Hour
long video so I uploaded it to YouTube
which is very weird because the original
Quran for Sleep video was 10 hours long
and not
four uh Sarah
typo is that a typo too that strike one
but it gets worse so I responded oh that
makes sense to be honest it didn't
really basically one of the main
theories were that you made the video to
kind of harness the spiritual energy
from the people listening to the are you
invested cuz I was I was probably
invested bro I was like he's a good
Storyteller is I was like bro I was like
okay I want to know did you get it like
I was I was I was so invested I think if
my wife's watching this she called I Ed
a call when I was video come on said I
have to get to the it's got to be done
Sor even if even if you're not busy you
add that call
anyway yes nice Quran for those
affirmations kind of like stealing their
spiritual power to make Owen Brown come
back no that's not true people might ask
why the affirmations about Owen Brown
affirmation was a little
toxic affirmations about openen Brown
affirmation nice English bro I was angry
from Owen Brown over being dumped
because of a stranger that talked with
me for about 12 mens I was angry from
Owen Brown a stranger to talk with me
bro the longer this conversation goes
the more broken her English becomes bro
she's like me bro now the thing why I
was so suspicious about her weird
English was because in the original
Quran for Sleep video if you remember
the voice in the background was saying
Owen Brown is coming back York
University for me so I Googled York
University to see where that is and it's
in Canada the people in Canada speak
English so how does someone who goes to
a Canadian University make so many weird
errors when they're talking it doesn't
make much sense right like you think she
would speak perfect English so I needed
to Dick even deeper I am angry of zishan
I am angry of zishan Owen
brownie but that's true it to me I was
thinking do you think it's like one of
those students from an Arabic Arab
country Muslim country do you get it
maybe they came they can't speak English
properly but then again she's like she's
a Christian or she's not a Muslim so I'm
thinking maybe from the European I'm
just thinking when a person goes on
YouTube and they see a Quran video the
the most common sense or assumption is
that this has been uploaded by a upright
Muslim who wants the best for us bro it
ends up being a Christian woman yes who
has put secret stuff in there to get her
boyfriend back yeah bro this is this is
strengthens the case that you can't
trust what's online yes literally
literally so I asked her so you are a
Christian yes I am Christian and Owen
Brown is Christian too then why did you
choose the Quran we thought Owen Brown
was going to be a Muslim in a Haram
relationship Owen brownie alhamdulillah
he's not though since you're Christian
why not use verses from the Bible and
she's like because my Muslim friends
recommend to me listening Quran to cure
evil eye so I decided to try what why
would a Christian listen to the Quran
like I know that some Christians like
respect the Islam and stuff you know
that there kind of like a almost like a
brotherly love going on you know you
believe in your God I believe in my God
we don't have to fight and stuff I get
that why because Christians even know
when you see a group of people their
devotion the Quran would bro if I listen
to the Quran I will come to Islam just
by the Quran bro like forget the sh and
all that kind of stuff or I don't know
what bro just listen to the Quran bro
this cannot be from human being bro
sorry man do you get it so Christians
know this and that's how powerful Islam
is that they're like you know what let's
try and you've see many Christians you
get you have magicians a Russian
magician who saying oh I can't attack
Muslims because they pray bro the proof
is in the pudding bro the proof is in
the pudding that's why even Christians
are using the Quran I like pudding yes
and a lot of non-muslims they use the
Quran to put their kids to sleep you
know that really Muslim yes bro
non-muslims many non Muslims do like
some we stop people D like yeah you know
I play the Quran with my kids are
sleeping yes bro let's carry on why
would a Christian listen to the Quran
though doesn't make any sense it's not
your belief it's not your God right so
that's strike number two I'm sorry but
let's ask some more questions I think
the robotic voice also said something
about swallowing pills I overcome my
fear from swallowing pills I can swallow
pills easily I guess you had trouble
swallowing pills so you wanted to get
that sorted out too literally just speed
running just put everything that you
struggle with in this Quran reading BR
yes in the past I couldn't swallow pills
and I have to take some medications for
rest of life because I have a
non-curable disease that needs daily
medications oh God bro the non-curable
disease bro now there now there's
another layer bro now she also has an
uncurable disease that she needs daily
medications bro multiple multiple
medications strike three oh God bro now
now we go into the Sonic the Hedgehog
fanfiction bro and the thing she told me
next was even weirder than anything that
came before okay that's a pretty wild
story you got there the story didn't
finish okay continue please a few years
later Owen Brown tried to get me back
because he probably didn't find a good
girl to love him but I rejected him
because I had gotten over him okay now I
want to tell you an information for my
privacy if you you allow me please sure
Owen Brown is dead he died in a car
accident yeah must it I really want I
really want to search that up Owen Brown
in Canada dead I didn't get a chance to
I might do that and just see if this is
this for real like that's bizarre like
his dead like I don't know did this
woman like some the brother man I think
it caused him to die or thing no not
from putting when Jones will come to me
in York no of course I wouldn't but you
know she could have do s I don't know
bro like I think she hasn't tell the
full story I don't know yeah you
know bro this [__] is fake as [__] bro
this [__] is fake as [__] who are you
trying to fool man come on man what
actually for 14-year-old [__] dream
SMP fanfiction level bro I'm sorry man
this is not real at this point I
literally thought about just blocking
her and be asham for the rest of my life
but I'm not just going to let her off
the hook like that bro I've been so
invested in the story and now she's
coming up with these weird [__]
things going on in it I'm not just going
to end this chat without figuring out
who this person is okay I wanted to
expose her let me find some questions to
ask her about the story where she
literally cannot find a good excuse so I
looked at our chat again reading every
single message message over and over
again trying to find this one weird
inconsistency something where she
slipped up but I couldn't find anything
I've been going through this chat a
million times I can't find any concrete
evidence that she's bullshitting right
but then I remembered the emails did she
maybe slip up in the emails that she
sent me in the very beginning so I
opened up my Gmail clicked on our
conversation and then I found something
that I cannot Lea I didn't notice it in
the very beginning the truth with an F
was literally always there in those
[__] emails because usually you know
on Gmail when someone sends you an email
you can see the email address of the guy
who sent you the message right but
usually also right next to the email
address you can also see their first and
last name so because it's Sarah Ali the
name should be Sarah Ali right but it
wasn't her name on Gmail it was Osama
Hussein oh hell no Sarah Ali is
now is not Muslim she's a Christian s
Ali no she's not she's Osama Hussein
who's a Christian now Osama Hussein was
in love with Owen Brown Owen brownie
brownie who died and she's a Christians
my good Lord let's go I don't know who's
University student in Canada but let's
find out let's find out cuz it gets a
little bit more sinister
wait a minute who the [__] is that guy
what why is there a male Muslim first
and last name although she said she's a
woman called Sarah Ali and she's
Christian there are alarm bells in my
brain bro exploding exploding in my
brain so let me confront Sarah Ali and
see what she has to say about that all
right so your a Christian woman called
Sarah Ali huh but why is your name on
Gmail Osama Hussein though sounds like a
male Muslim name and then she responded
with the dumbest excuse I've ever heard
in my entire life I have Muslim friends
that all my real name Sarah Ali is one
of my friends name shall I complete my
story bro what the hell is this excuse
she even bro she skipped my she skipped
my question bro she didn't even say why
her name is so bro she's like your my
name is
Sarah okay so my finger was on the Block
button like on your mom and I was
basically ready to end this conversation
her story is just way too sus to be real
but before I could block her she sent me
another message finally share with
people my new channel
what
youtube.com/ theal Sarah Ali and then I
clicked on it and it just looks like a
normal YouTube channel joins March 2020
the original Quran for Sleep video was
uploaded in 2019 and this channel was
created in 2020 I was like wait a minute
if this is some random 14-year-old guy
who's who's just trying to get my
attention did he really create a channel
Channel back in 2020 to troll me 4 years
later although he would have no idea
that I would even make the
video now it's getting a
bit confused so I asked her for proof
that it's actually her channel one more
thing can you send me a screen recording
of your YouTube studio so that I see
that it's actually your channel and then
she
responded I can't beu
I changed the channel name so people
don't find me do you not have access to
the channel at all anymore I have assess
okay I will send you a video later Bey I
have a lot of email bro what the [__] I
thought she's she's not going to send me
anything she's literally just going to
block me on Discord and I'm just left
here wondering what the hell I just
experienced at least that's what I
thought because Sarah Ali did come back
and she brought some gifts for
me hi again I opened the YouTube channel
and I discovered that I removed
everything but I have YouTube email
screenshot for
you a screenshot and what do we have
here she got an email from YouTube about
a takeown requests on two videos one of
them called Quran for Sleep which makes
sense because the original Quran for
Sleep video did get taken down for
copyright did she fake this I don't know
and then she sent me more screenshots of
her YouTube Studio channel name Sarah
Ali 36,000 subscribers and the actual
Sarah Ali Channel also has 36,000
subscribers bro is this real but I
remember in the first screenshot that
she sent me her profile picture was
green right so I was like wait a minute
why is the profile picture in her new
screenshot blue but her old one is green
so let me open up her YouTube channel
and just compare profile pictures right
I went to Google I typed in Sarah Ali
YouTube to find the original Channel I
click on the
channel and I get this I'm the real
Sarah Ali wait for my collaboration with
a famous YouTuber
bro ain't no [__] way bro ain't no
[__] way bro ain't no [__] way bro
wait you're the actual Sarah
Ali yes it is me Sarah Ali Ali Ali Al
how is this possible the the typos the
the name the inconsistencies in the
story nothing made sense but it but it's
real it's her you even see the
screenshot that she sent me in the first
email do you believe me now I have to
ask why exactly me out of all those
hundreds of people that made videos
about you some of them with millions of
views why did you choose me to tell your
story because I watched your video
before and I think you're a nice guy
with a kind heart I thought I can trust
you to share my story I feel like if I
share my story with another YouTuber he
might leak my information I also saw
your donating to streamer video before
and the videos with your grandmother it
were
funny well that's very kind of you was
that basically the story
wait I have something to say to the
world finally I learned from my
experience not to believe everything you
see on the internet because most of what
you find there is likely a lie or not
the full truth truth I created the Quran
for Sleep video for myself I only
listened to it for 2 or 3 days for about
30 minutes each day then I forgot about
it completely and I abandoned the
YouTube channel then for some reason it
went viral by accident lots of people
thought the video is cursed or black
magic but it was never meant to be that
next few people claimed that Sarah Ali
made this video as a gift for her Muslim
ex however neither Owen Brown nor I are
Muslims I was only interested in Quran
if I didn't abandon my channel and had I
known that my Quran for Sleep video
would get views I would have made it
private or deleted it immediately
there's been some people who re-uploaded
the videos under my name on YouTube and
Spotify however that's not me I'm sorry
for Muslim people to misuse their holy
book Quran I hope they accept my apology
oh so what do you think as Muslims I
mean it's coming to the
end
um yeah I mean I don't think it was
intentional I think she didn't know she
spoke to Muslim friends they said listen
to the Quran because that's what we're
told like Bak is very put in the house
listening to it it's yeah when it comes
to evil the Quran is a the story makes
sense to be honest it's a bit of a buzz
kill to be honest not even a buzz kill
anticlimax like we expected it to be
Sinister and this and that she just
ended up being some average woman who
liked somebody and then her friends
advised her and she was like okay this
is a bit long uh I don't have space on
my phone let me just put it on YouTube
and then but I don't understand you can
listen to the Quran to Kure the evil eye
but what's the thing of Owen uh was it
Owen Brown Owen Brown this the those are
affirmations so in
Psychology they you repeat something
again and again is
um and then even if you're conscious you
listen to something again and again and
then it has an effect on your
unconscious mind you can also do that
when you're sleeping there's like sleep
hypnosis videos in which you just play
stuff and they just carry on talking
talking talking and as you go to sleep
it's like if I'm in depression I will
get over my depression yeah stuff like
that you are strong you can do this it's
important because we are told that that
the prophet told us that Allah is to his
servants how you think of him so having
that good thought about Allah and the
future it's it's it's it's good I mean
yeah but I mean for her to do oh the
Quran is a little bit bizarre and weird
but well there you go bro sometimes with
relationships get you to do some really
desperate stuff and that's why it's
Haram and plus online you just don't
know which video is going to go viral so
many people after you've interviewed
them they go oh you know what I didn't
know it would pop off that much or I
didn't know that take down I mean look
at Muhammad hos I mean he mashah he
speaks so well and he's covered so many
different topics but un bowns to him or
you know something that he probably even
he's confused is like the only thing
that is going viral is that one meme of
him going
brother brother but I think it's
interesting because a lot of people
channeled that and found the actual
video and watched it his actual talk so
Allah Works in his serious ways but
let's finish off let's see what was the
conclusion nice unbelievable so yeah if
you always want to know
video is all about this is it Sol Al
thank you for talking to me and freaking
out for a little bit I appreciate your
honesty if you're someone who has AER to
tell me or a
dark
[Music]
it well I mean uh that's it guys so U we
do know it wasn't s again from what she
saying
can be we don't know again don't listen
to anything that has some kind of
background noises when it comes to the
Quran just read the Quran yourself yeah
exactly read it yourself and I mean you
can play we play in the house Etc but
like from the app I've got like the apps
that you some
reputable channels in which you know
that but you don't have Quran there we
have in our da yes so yeah that's it I
mean Sarah Ali whoever you are whereever
you might watch this video cuz the
video's gone viral um look as Muslims I
mean I can't speak for everyone like
obviously we don't believe you've done
it intentionally but again Islam is the
truth if you're watching this this is
why Islam if you think about it
relationships this look how much it
harmed you look how much it got you to
do something like that whatever it is
for that matter Islam is a cure for all
of this so we ask you to accept Islam
look into Islam this might be a reason
why you should look into you know the
Quran is a cure so look into it we
believe in that God is one uh we believe
in the Gin kind we believe in EV ey all
this kind of stuff is true so uh and I'm
sure maybe you've witnessed it for
yourself so I would highly highly
recommend you um if you want you can get
in contact with myself you don't have to
it's not a must um but yeah like um look
into Islam I think it genuinely will be
a solution for you and it's a solution
for mankind inshallah um and yeah that's
what I've SE last words from you
bro do give me your thoughts on this
video
inah okay Zan I'm going to be here